so if we had done this list before
season eight I think would have been
pretty different
[Applause]
[Music]
so Game of Thrones has come to an end
and we're gonna do the same thing that
we did for Gotham and we're gonna go
through our top ten characters and just
as we did that time we don't know who's
on each other's lists and we're gonna
reveal them to you the same time that we
reveal them to each other the one thing
that we did sort of figure out just in a
little bit back and forth is this is a
Lannister free list there are no
Lannisters to be found because I'm sorry
Tyrion you didn't have anything good
after season five he just didn't yeah
yeah drink give me new things and then
you just kept drinking and let's stop no
one thing yeah you're drunk until you
didn't know things anymore that's what
it's no yeah but this is not a complaint
list this is a positive listening today
though that we agreed that like there
are a fair amount of characters that
would have been higher or would have
been on our list that after season eight
did not make it yes that I mean that
intro wasn't just for the sake of a joke
this list would have been very different
a year ago yeah I mean I probably would
have had Jamie to cuz I really like
Jamie at first and like I let it so
we'll acknowledge that at the front end
but from here okay number 10 so first of
all Tyrell yeah
Tyrell ends and a stark yeah yeah a
little direwolf yes ghost that you got
for
yeah so yeah so I mean I'll go first
yeah Ned like gone for a while now but I
he was he was one of my initial hook ins
to the show first of all I love Sean
Bean I love Sean Bean everything I've
ever seen him in and he's the character
is just really great because he baited
he basically ultimately suffers from the
fatal condition of being himself he
can't he cannot be anything other than
who he is and that is ultimately what
gets him killed and what I find
interesting about that is normally when
that happens it's because who someone is
like has what is agreed to be a
fundamental flaw like they can't hide
the fact that they're a coward or
they're self-serving or like he's none
of those things he's a good he's a good
honest noble dude but he is that so
strongly that it gets him killed
and that yeah dad I love that he was
actually sort of I asked you who you're
like if Ned was on there cuz I was
considering him and he was a very strong
contender for me so I was like okay
we'll talk about Ned at some point so I
will put someone else on the line yes I
did I did confirm to you that I had
Ned's so that you could you so that you
could put somebody else but yeah he's
just like great I love his scenes with
Arya in the beginning and his ocean ship
with her yes her so well he really
understands her and his death just puts
everything in motion after yeah you know
and it's so shocking here and so
heart-wrenching so yeah good choice so
Marjorie Marjorie much like it's Sean
Bean it's Natalie Dormer and she legit
legit just like that scheming
intelligence personified like you can
just see it working in her eyes she's
basically training to be her grandma
um but she also have this sweetness and
kindness to her like she's the you know
she's shows Tommen like the first
kindness he's ever seen
she's it if Searcy had a heart I feel
like she'd be Margaery yeah maybe uh I
don't know maybe maybe that's a stretch
but like I'm making the comparison there
that the that the level of scheming is
there I could see that okay I couldn't I
could understand um you know she deals
with this whole situation of her brother
being with her her husband essentially
and just kind of like it's kind of like
their beard and it's kind of this weird
relationship yeah well she knows exactly
what's going on she's like no like it's
fine yes this this is a political
marriage anyway I get it got it figured
out um but I do feel like she has that
goodness and she does really care about
the people which had not been happening
for a while Jim she would have made an
amazing Queen um I really it does make
me sad the way she died that she died on
mass with a group of people so that
really heard but I just really enjoyed
her for the few seasons she was in um
and I I mean I enjoyed that League
dormer anyways so I just thought - let's
be honest
yes yes okay so not number nine yeah
ready oh yes so that this is the one
like flat-out antagonistic character who
made my list because I felt like this
show had give us so many good villains
that like I wanted somebody on here
mm-hmm
and for me it's gonna be him because
most of the other great villains that
have been on here you know Joffrey
Ramsay characters like that you know I
can look at them and go I was really
glad to see you die
but you also weren't as much fun to be
around up until that point like you were
so twisted you finally getting your
comeuppance was cathartic
but with Littlefinger because he again
back when the show was about political
maneuvering and manipulation he did that
just as well as the characters we
inherently like more like Tyrion like
Margaery
but he was he was just all slimy in the
way he did it but I liked that he had he
had that because he had that same level
of intelligence and approach in his
manipulation he was fun to have around
in a way reminiscent of those other
characters but he was still slimy enough
that when he finally got it was like
yeah yeah and and we are still gonna
have that characters we love to hate
right on this so I mean we might well
I'm debating whether or not we'll do
that as a separate list I will see okay
okay all right so he's kind of like I
I've been thinking about him recently
and he's really on here because of the
whole progression he made so I didn't
like him at first is he the only one who
moved up because of season 8 as opposed
to being moved down he's not the only
one but one one of you one of you
because everyone there's a fair amount
that just stayed where they were yeah
and then there was like two that I would
say moved up there was a lot that went
like by Brienne sorry yeah yeah but yeah
I and it wasn't just season 8 I mean
definitely that turning moment where he
throws that girl off the tower and
decides to save Sansa was just like yes
yes go Theon go go and um but I also
loved that he never well by the end yes
he makes a full redemption
there are those moments of has
hesitation and cowardice and everything
and I love I kind of loved that I hated
him at first and then by the end I was
like oh yeah you know I what I like
about his journey and and this is this
is a hard thing to do well is that he
had stumbles along the way that still
felt right because often times when
these kinds of stories try and have
someone redeeming but then stumbly it
just it feels it just feels like we're
running on a hamster wheel but it would
feel like he did make progress he
stumbled but he's a little further than
he was and he'll get a little further
and then he'll stumble again but he'll
get a little further so it it actually
managed to balance that he is getting
better but he has still got a lot of
issues and actor played the trauma so he
did he really did I was really impressed
with him and um a good Christmas tree
with the woman who played Yara as well
yep
really yeah convincing scenes with them
together loved his his ending scene or
his scene with Sansa were there yeah I'm
checking in with each other off that
that pulled up my heart and made me tear
up but yeah I I do really love their
friendship and just this like
understanding of shared trauma they had
after yeah all right so moving on to
number eight yep
ooh she barely missed my list oh really
yeah
and wait and like I love her to death
but it was one of those cases where
you're in it so little and like her
she's so good I do love her I absolutely
love her but it was one of those things
of like have I built you up to be more
than you actually were in my mind she
takes out a giant nose she does we
wanted her for the Iron Throne yes we
did
yeah like is our first pick out like a
boss Alec bus in the bus out like
it's like yeah I why don't I just go
forth okay she was just like a Duff
factor for me I know she's only in like
three episodes but anytime she came on I
was like yeah you tell him I don't know
who you're gonna tell off but you're
gonna tell someone off and she's just so
tough she's like this pint-sized like
boss you know and it's just great like
at first I thought she would be like a
mini Aria kind of but she wasn't she was
kind of her own brand of sass and you
know awesomeness um I don't mean she
dies taking out a giant yes she does I
was devastated that she died and I
didn't think she was gonna die that
suddenly but like what a way to go yeah
and I also wanted her to be a zombie
longer it's like she would have been
terrifying
hahaha but yes she is she's who we
wanted I mean she is yeah
if the Iron Throne was not gonna be
melted down which I always figured it
would be I she was the one I wanted on
it so Davos partly it's the actor Liam
Cunningham
you'll see him again on my list by the
way I I figured he would be yeah like
he's great and he's got he he just again
it's a great balance of elements because
he does have that sort of nobility to
him but he's got just enough of the
rough edges that you see his history of
having been something much less noble
than he currently is and he also had
great rapport with basically anybody
they ever put him in a room with which
is always a good thing yeah I'm not sure
I've got too much more to say than that
as a game he was just here and I'm like
oh you're in a scene so I like this he
made everything a bit better
he's a very sympathetic character I'll
get into it more but yeah yeah good
choice okay so number seven oh yeah I
almost forgot about him but I do like
but again wasn't around seeing like that
even as I made this argument about like
I know I'm gonna help myself as a
hypocrite for this one but I just I
guess she made more of an impression for
me it and that's fine but you made more
that's why I'm fair
there's only one God His name is death
and there's only one thing that we say
to death not today is still it's in
season one it is still my favorite line
I just I love his swagger I love the
fact that he's like this tall I love
just how smooth the guy he's he's like
if inigo montoya
didn't have the daddy issues and just
learned to be a kick-ass fencer mm-hmm
like and that's just yes yes all of that
and yes yeah he's good no I hadn't
really thought about him but yeah you
see he's good fun he's a lot of fun yeah
gone too soon all right yeah so Oh
Elena Elena Elena I always say only old
Liana for some reason Elena Tyrell um
love her I'm gay I'm hoping she's on
your legs I'll get to talk about her
again okay um
much like you love the knot today that I
love that tell sir oh so good that was
just like out like like best mic drop
like know that that's a Westeros right
you're off right there that's an exit
that is an exit
just like she's just so good she's I
mean the actress Diana Rigg like what
what else could you say I know and like
here's the thing you I love her little I
don't her little headpiece
i I'm just gonna mention that because I
really love that because it made her
look like so it helped with the purity
and like but she's just so not she's so
not see when you mentioned the margins I
give Marjorie like it's like she could
always figure everything out I'm like
she can but not like oh and just like
she took out Joffrey thank you and they
didn't die so spectacularly and turned
purple and choke and like oh and then
just rub Jamie's nose in it and like oh
oh she's wonderfully awful and I love
her and like yeah and I kind of also
wonder which obviously there's spoilers
abound here yeah if you haven't figured
that out by now I think of bran taking
over I think she would have had outward
disapproval but there would have been a
smirk yes I feel like that would be it
I just shake of the head but like a
little a little smirk like are you
serious
alright then okay so number six we
should have thought of something to do
like we should have like had a shot or
something no we didn't well maybe it
won't be our only toy but we'll see
we'll see but yeah like so I did have to
think about this because immediately
they seemed to not know all that much of
what to do with him and in the way in
the last year season but to contrast it
with say Tyrion the lack of things for
him to do didn't result in an actual
diminishment of his character just
resulted in him showing up a little less
yeah and it kind of made sense of the
situation because like he's a guy who
manipulates the the Royal chambers but
once he's not in King's Landing anymore
you know he's just in an environment
where what
does doesn't get called for as much so I
don't feel like the lattice eases
knocked him the way that they knock
Tyrion he makes an excellent background
character he does like I do really like
I kind of love that he's never in the
forefront and that suits what he does so
well that I forget about him and then
I'm like oh yeah I I love I love his
soft-spoken Asst and I love his
sincerity at times like when he aunt
when Ned start Ned Stark asks him who do
you service is the realm
somebody has to it's like the sincerity
that comes through in that moment is
like oh dang you're not about loyalty to
any of these houses you're just like
what is going to cause the least damage
to the people who actually have to live
he'll he does actually care too but like
his ways of manipulating and his means
to get there you're like oh oh how did
okay like you seem evil but you want the
right thing but the way you get there oh
my goodness he doesn't get hung up on on
the means he nothing he he makes his
call on what he thinks is the best thing
to do is like however I got to get this
done well we'll get this done yeah I
mean we pretty yeah we're pretty much an
agreement he's great and scenes with
Tyrion yes I like you know even when I
was not quite as happy with Tyrion I was
like oh this will be better because he's
with varies and they'll be at like full
scheming potential it's it's all good
and also probably drinking so halfway
through so moving on Davos I talked
about him what what do you care to add
um he's just my soft spot but like I
just have such sympathy for him I loved
him
early on when like he was locked up and
Shireen was teaching him to read like
that just hit me oh my god and then I
loved that he figured out Melisandre
right away and was against her
we I really did not like her and like
when he lost his son see I actually need
to go back and re-watch that because
that didn't hit me that hard but it's
cuz it felt like I didn't know if I
liked him yet when that happened well
keep in Maya I also read the books so
that we're gonna get into this with I
think my third favorite character who I
also really loved in the books so that
influenced a little bit oh my love for
him and why he's up high but like that I
think I don't know if it hit me more in
the series or the books they've kind of
meshed together in my mind
fair enough that he's just this good
moral man who keeps fighting for and
keeps like serving these awful people
yeah and that and instead of being like
with Tyrion where I'm like you're dumb I
just feel real sympathy for him instead
and I don't know why quite that is oh I
know goodness shine through more than
obviously Tyrion but the thing is is
that Davos doesn't Bank himself on his
brains I think is the difference I don't
mean to say that like he's done but like
he's never sold himself as I'm smart and
figure stuff out
whereas Tyrion does so when Tyrion acts
he does something dumb as a result of
that is in direct contradiction of who
he supposedly is whereas with Davos he
never claims to be that so when he is
tied to somebody despicable despicable
it doesn't call his character into
question the same way yeah cuz he's
almost serves as a contrast to them yeah
look at you are so moral but look at who
you're serving and like yeah and I
really like his voice too you're kind of
doing a smooth voices oh I just I really
uh I just want to hug him
I really adore Davos like I was always
just happy to see him and like
if there was like a comfort feeling to
it okay so bron-bron was basically if
you saw the list I did on Gotham or that
we did
he's my equivalent to to Victor Zsasz in
a tissue
literally every time he shows up I'm
smiling yeah and and he is in some lousy
scenes some lousy storylines he was tied
up in the pointless crap that went on at
Dorne pointless but he was still so
better in the books let me point out
Doran is better in the book I'll take
your word for it I mean it couldn't it's
hard to not be but in any case even in
something like that he was still good
and I still had fun with him and I just
I loved that he never lets the mercenary
nature slip in that like no it's not
that I don't like you it's just someone
who pays me well enough I'm gonna kill
you that's what I do
what like I told you that I kind of
almost wished he had like shot me Jamie
shoot Jamie yeah do it you would have
saved us some some heartache it's
evening and not like not like emotional
gut-punch heartache but just like oh
really
heartache but any anyways ready to move
up okay let me just continue the
conversation okay so again he's also
good comic relief yeah yes and we need
that and I know it's a trope to have
this like rogue cell sort kind of but he
plays it so well and that's a good route
well what I love is that is that like I
said he never loses that because so he's
not like the rogue with a heart of gold
he's like oh no no he's just the room
yeah which to me makes him refreshing
and he's so good and scenes with Tyrion
and Jaime like I think if I continue to
love the two of them
more he would have been a little higher
but yeah and just his love of Rasul
especially in that last higher priority
one for rebuilding King's Landing though
brothels so he's just a lot of fun he is
so are yeah mom dad it's been since
summer ten since we had a stark turn up
oh right
Aria is Aria was just a cool kid early
on and she stayed cool and she got
cooler and she was just a badass by the
end and that was she's one of the she's
one of the characters where I don't
think there's there's actually anything
particularly surprising about her story
I think it largely goes where you expect
it to but it's also one of the only ones
that does mmm-hmm that doesn't take a
major divergence or end really abruptly
or end up in a place where you're like
wait how do we get here
she just kind of goes on this journey
and there's something kind of nice about
having at least one character walk the
path you expect them to
she's also well I didn't expect her to
live first of all well yeah but that's
what that still does she still the same
trajectory you just thought it would get
her killed
yeah well yeah I will be talking about
her later but yeah she is she also never
bores me
even though you're right like her story
not mine never bores me I'm always glad
to see her I'm like you are right she is
what hurt her path and her progression
makes sense
I do like at the end though that she
kind of walks away from it and it's like
I'm gonna continue exploring the world
and I'm and that makes sense to me I'm
like yeah I'm gonna give up this
assassin business she's still gonna
probably kill a lot of people it's not
gonna be like number one priorities
crossing names off her list is there
even anyone left to is on her list
list is done isn't it yeah I think I
mean she didn't kill all of them but
they're all dead
yeah I think so I think she gets to walk
away yeah yeah it maybe not start a new
list like yeah I'm good yeah so all
right
ready for number three yeah oh yeah go
for it so you will see her later well
this is a bit like Barbara Kean for me
with Gore with Gotham because she she
easily gets most improved oh yeah
cuz I did not like her for a while and
the but and the reason this is actually
the reason she gets above Aria for me
because as much as I actually don't even
think it's a negative that Arya's arc
goes where you expect it to to be
surprised by where somebody ends up and
have it work as opposed to just oh and
and now Daenerys burns this whole thing
it's like wait what like but to have
someone go on a trajectory that makes
sense but isn't what you would have
expected for them that's really
rewarding television that's really
rewarding long-form storytelling and I
think Sansa really embodies that quite
well in terms of you know the the vapid
almost like pretty girl that she starts
out as to what to hell that she goes
through you know initially at the hands
of Joffrey and then Ramsay good god and
then having her own personal catharsis
getting to deal with and you firsthand
take that take participation in the
elimination of Ramsey and Littlefinger
and then to with not not her baggage
dealt with because it's not like you
just pack off your baggage but have
gotten to get closure on those things to
evolve further into the ruler that she
became by the end like I had this is
good stuff she wins the game fair give
anyone when she won like and what a
journey to get
and I'll talk about that more in terms
of ascending to power yeah she did it
right yeah like she figured out how to
play it really well - yeah so uh um I
mean I get it
it is a simplistic desire he has and
like to kill his brother take out his
abusive brother but it works so well
and I he's a simple guy it's a simple
storyline but man does he sell it and
he's great in scenes with Sansa and Arya
yeah he's so good and brings out so much
in them and one of my favorite episodes
is where his goal is to get chicken our
goal is to get a pony and by the end
like he has chicken she has a pony and
I'm just like this was a great episode
like you do not need more goals than
this like I'm just happy for them to be
riding along he's in some of the best
fights like when he takes down yeah yeah
that's good I really did enjoy
cleganebowl I know you had a few issues
with it yes I did but like it's it
worked
yeah um I just I loved him in the books
I just I love that he comes back and
achieves his goal it's I know it's
simple but I just I really like him and
I love that at the end you know he's
like re you don't want this you don't
want what I have and like she steps back
and of that and that's like that is how
the Hound does kindness and I gotta love
that no I agree I'll get to talk about
him later oh oh okay so number two okay
here we go I guess this is my number two
okay
she you'll notice there's no number no
she has been agonizing for the last hour
she has been agonizing she's been she's
been sitting right over there going I
don't know
I don't and like remember if you watch
our Gotham video I was like well you
know my number one is the number one
same reason that my number one for
Gotham is gonna be number one and now
it's not number one is number yeah so I
love her she's great and yeah I mean we
said most of it um I love how sure of
herself she is even as a child like nope
that's not me
and like that that comes back there's no
great callbacks in her storyline which I
love um she gets to take out so many
like people I hate like she gets to
check out Walder Frey you know she gets
to take out Littlefinger
I know some people were like well I
don't think it makes sense for her to
take out the knight King makes sense to
me it makes perfect sense to me I mean
she's an assassin she's on her home turf
like they're like how did she sneak up
on him she's little they just showed her
sneaking around the crypts a bunch and
not getting hot like she's on her home
turf like yeah it makes sense that she
takes out the 19 to me at least um I
didn't love the like let's lose my
virginity to Gendry storyline that was a
little that was a misstep but not so
much not some of the colossal missteps
that we and took on the scale of season
8 missteps it was on the lower end and
even that like the way it happens it's
true to her character which is why it's
better than what happens with Randy I
don't like it as a note to be played but
it is at least consistent with who she
is and if she was gonna do that that's
how she would do it and I forgot okay so
yes I don't know how much I have to add
about Elena Tyrell just boss Oh absolute
bomb yeah I knew you loved her I expect
her to be that high but I I feel ooh
that's her she's great Oh Diana Rigg
owns that
part so expertly wide about it - I know
like and she just just sits in the back
quietly watching and making notes and
totally understanding everything that is
going on I know I love her scenes with
the high Sparrow - yes which again like
not quite in enough and I don't like
obviously lion-o was not in it that much
either
but I I did love him he was great and
what I liked about the I mean it's worth
a book I'll just mention it quickly what
I liked about the high Sparrow was that
he was so sincere about what he was
saying as opposed to it being a
political ploy I liked the fact that
that threw everybody off their games
like wait he's not just saying this for
power he means it he actually oh crap I
don't know what to do with this guy I
know the reason he didn't make the list
is because I kind of like the impact he
had on the show um um a little bit more
than the character and I also don't like
the rest of the sparrows like as a thing
but I do like him yeah but yeah Elena
there are some great roles for older
actors in this but I don't think any of
them even come close to her she
absolutely young talking to to Marjorie
like her very first scenes just make it
so clear she knows exactly what she's
doing she's the queen of the betrayal
darkness oh man would you believe in the
South Park reference she she hold she
holds the tax lien on the betray yes
lover okay so number one I know what
your number one is now so number one I
cannot expect that to be your number one
I didn't know you liked him that much
I'm I I always liked him I was never
unhappy to see him and but it was in a
slightly less superficial way that then
say bran because bran I always liked
having around for a bit of a chuckle a
bit of a laugh
the hound I always like to have around
because maybe I get a chuckle maybe I
get a laugh maybe I get to see some
great acting of a really broken human
being maybe I get a really kick-ass
action scene maybe I get a terrific
better chemistry between him and either
of those stark sisters like like one of
my favorite moments in the show it's
from season four he and are you go to
what is it the veil um you're hoping to
to get Aria to her aunt and they get
there and the guards like no she's she's
dead
and the house is layers like it are you
just starts laughing like I love that I
like that so good together like he's
trying for once he's trying to do a
decent thing and the world's just
crapping what a warrant and they're
bringing kicks his butt to his like
that's what you get for trying to do a
decent thing dude and yeah and he's so
good and he he has an understanding of
what he is and that what he is is not a
good thing and no one should aspire to
be it but he still commits to being that
and there's it's it's a again the best
of these characters are really well
balanced in terms of him having just
enough awareness to not be frustrating
to watch because someone who's as
self-destructive as he is but doesn't
realize it that gets frustrating but he
is just enough self-awareness where
you're like oh man you know you're
damaged and you also know you can't stop
it yeah that's I mean he he is
simplistic but also very complex now
that you're talking
he has simplistic desires but he's not a
simplistic character yeah
so lady songs Queen in the north
um she definitely has the best story arc
in the whole series I think
yeah um I only actually hated her kind
of in the first season because I even
saw the gradual progression and seasons
two and three cuz there's at one point
where like she outwits Joffrey who's
being unkind to someone and like tricks
him and like it's a very subtle thing
but it's like planting the seeds of like
know she's watching and she's always
watching like that when she's in King's
Landing she's just you can see her just
quietly observing and picking up things
in that like seasons two and three once
she realizes how awful Joffrey and
Cersei are she's like starting to figure
it out I think it's season three I
started to turn around on her because
season two like she was the seeds were
planted but she still had like in the
Battle of Blackwater this city's getting
seized and she's down there going
everything will be fine shall we sing a
hymn I'm like but but again knowing
again it's true to where she started and
the trajector of where she ends up is
fantastic yes I see what you're saying
there but there's also I think she was
still that's not a bad thing that she's
saying that I think there was like she
was slowly losing that hopefulness and
that sweet yes no and like I get it but
I'm saying I didn't I'm not even saying
that's a fault in the arc I'm just
saying ice didn't warm to her until a
little bit later because because that
kind of stuff was still in there until
she had fully shed it I wasn't really on
board with that's fair um yeah
I loved her scenes with Turtles when
they hang out they're pretty awesome you
know you know what gets trained by some
pretty awesome women if the structure of
the darrell's had just teamed up at the
beginning this whole thing would have
gone so much better for everybody so
much better
[Music]
I loved her hand and like little finger
and Ramsey's death and just like the
satisfaction she got from them and like
especially playing little finger was
beautiful to watch I just love where she
ends up I'm like this feels right like
cuz yeah I also understood like I didn't
ever really want her to rule all of
Westeros cuz there's a part of me that's
like she hates King's Landing
oh she does not want to return there
like there's no way but yeah and I also
really love that she figured out Danny
like before anyone else and was like
you're not good stuff like this is not
gonna end well because she'd seen so
much and I just think sophie Turner did
a great job just slowly evolving that
character and just I just love watching
her watch other people and I love the
respect that she and Aria have for each
other at the end I love her with a hound
like she's just yeah so that's I'm I'm
feeling okay with her as my top choice
though probably by tomorrow I'll be like
oh god I love Aria so much I mean if I
could just be like number one is the
stark sisters done you think that that
would have worked so I just that bit
like oh well that's our list folks
thanks for joining us who are your
favorite characters from Game of Thrones
I and also I mean between the two of us
who would have ended up on the Iron
Throne
let's talk about it hope I do as well
cause buttons and links and there's
patreon and there's the like button
which I guess is really important these
days and subscribing and all sorts of
stuff click on things or don't it's up
to you because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings sometimes
with Liz and until it goes and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]